Gruppen haben gestern den Nachtzug nach
Kiew um Solidarität mit der Ukraine zu
demonstrieren und damit einer weit
verbreiteten Förderung nachzukommen aber
Russlands Krieg gegen Ukraine geht mit
unverminderter Härte weiter ein Ende ist
momentan außer Sichtweite oder nur mit
einer riesen Portion Fantasie erkennbar
Steinmeier in Kiew wie muss der Westen
Handeln jetzt in der phoenix-runde
heute war ich dankbar herr Präsident
dass ich einen ganzen Tag lang durch die
Augen der Ukraine
auf die Lage im Krieg blicken konnte und
ich konnte mit vielen sprechen
vieles sehen kann am Ende dieses Tages
sagen ich bin wirklich voller
aufrichtiger Bewunderung für den Mut
für die Unbeugsamkeit den
Freiheitswillen und die Tapferkeit der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine ich danke
Deutschland für klares Signal
tempolitischen der politischen der
Geschäftswelt dafür dass die
Investitionen in unseren Staat als
künftiges Mitglied der Europäischen
Union danke Deutschland für die
Bereitschaft uns beide Energie Resilienz
zu unterstützen heute ja die beiden
Staatspräsidenten und der Präsidenten
und Deutschland und auch der Ukraine
Frank Walter Steinmeier und wurde die
mir selensky heute abend in Kiew der
eine eher emotional der andere eher
sachlich und damit herzlich Willkommen
bei uns meine Gäste hier im Studio
Natalia
sie sind Politikwissenschaftlerin von
der Allianz ukrainischer Organisationen
Angelika Claussen ist von den
internationalen Ärzten Verhütung des
Atomkriegs
Professor Klaus siegbers
Politikwissenschaftler unter anderem
für internationale und osteuropäische
Politik und Wolfgang Richter ist bei uns
Sicherheitsexperte der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und
Bundeswehroberst außer Diensten Frau
brichanitzka wie willkommen war
eigentlich der Bundespräsident in Kiew
sehr willkommen und sehr erwartet seit
langer Zeit das war sehr schön dass
jetzt auch
obwohl wir den flächendeckenden Krieg
schon seit acht Monaten eigentlich haben
der kriegt seit acht Jahren andauernd im
neunten Jahr ist dass der Herr
Bundespräsident Steinmeier jetzt im
Käfer die Frage habe ich ja deswegen
gestellt weil vor sechs Monaten war ja
noch nicht willkommen
wir sprechen von der Politik also von
der ukrainischen Politik von der
Einladung und der sogenannten Ausladung
die Lage war nicht geklärt ich bin sehr
froh dass das heute dass wir heute eine
neue Situation haben und der Zeichen der
Solidarität von Herrn Steinmeier gesetzt
werden konnte also wird man denn vor Ort
in Kiew für Frank-Walter Steinmeier
seine frühere russlandfreundliche
Haltung verzeihen
ich weiß es nicht aber mein Eindruck ist
dass die wichtigsten Politiker und
Politikerinnen in Kiew
sehr pragmatische Menschen sind der eher
nach vorne als nach hinten schauen und
unter dem Aspekt macht das einfach nicht
viel Sinn noch monatelang der
nachzukarten und danach zu suchen also
ich denke schon sie wollen nach vorne
gucken ich denke wir müssen auf eines
achten bei all dem reden was jetzt seit
ein paar Wochen sich sehr stark nach
vorne geschoben hat über Wiederaufbau
der Kanzler hat heute eine große große
wiederaufbauveranstaltung hier in Berlin
geleitet zusammen mit der
kommissionspräsidentin
soll man nicht übersehen ja wieder
aufbröst nötig aber im Augenblick haben
wir anderen Festen Krieg der läuft und
wir müssen zunächst mal darüber
nachdenken was wird mit dem Krieg diese
Ampel Valenz werden wir ansprechen Herr
Richter Nebelkerzen zu werfen das
scheint ja eine beliebte russische
Disziplin zu sein angeblich so hört man
aus Moskau bereitet die Ukraine die
Explosion einer schmutzigen Bombe vor
also eine Konvent mit konventionellen
Sprengsatz aber mit nuklearen
Bestandteilen also zu nuklearen
verseuchtung um diese Explosion dann
Russland in die Schuhe zu schieben was
steckt dahinter hinter dieser Äußerung
und zunächst einmal könnte dahinter
stecken dass man selbst ein Szenario
vorbereiten will in dem solche
Eskalationen möglich sind man will den
Westen darauf aufmerksam machen dass man
einen Staat der so etwas vorbereitet
nicht unterstützen soll also es ist ja
vor allen Dingen ein politisches Signal
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es
irgendwo jemanden gibt wieder in Kiew
eigentlich sollte es auch nicht in
Moskau sein der irgendein nukleares
Szenario ernsthaft erwägt weil es immer
auch auf eigene Truppen auf die eigene
Bevölkerung zurückfallen würde und vor
allen Dingen auch auf die Bevölkerung da
ist ja auch der irrw jetzt dieser
Politik die man ja jetzt als Russen
sieht die man ein Gemeinden will und sie
würde dann eben auch betroffen aber vor
allen Dingen auch die Streitkräfte also
es macht keinen Sinn und ich halte das
eher für eine politische Äußerung für
Klausen kriegsverursachen Kriegstreiber
ist ja Putin müsste die Friedensbewegung
der ist hier auch angehören nicht sehr
viel stärker an den kriemelherrn
appellieren den Angriff zu beenden und
sich zurückzuziehen
das tun wir bereits also wir haben ganz
konkrete Schritte unternommen die IPPNW
hat das gemacht also meine Organisation
die internationale Organisation der
Ärztin und Ärzte zur Verhütung des
Atomkriegs wir haben gleich zu Beginn
des Krieges also kurz danach das war im
März haben wir einen Appell gemacht weil
Putin ja schon am Anfang des Krieges
auch mit dem Atomwaffeneinsatz gedroht
hat und das ist für uns völlig
indiskutabel und inhumanitär und
unmöglich und wir haben einen Appell
gemacht wo wir sowohl Russland als auch
die USA aufgefordert haben auf den
Einsatz von also eine gemeinsame
rechtsverbindliche Erklärung zu machen
um auf den Einsatz von Ersteinsatz von
Atomwaffen zu verzichten und haben mit
dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen gar nicht
gedroht nein die USA haben nicht gedroht
aber wichtig ist es es war ja so dass
Anfang des Jahres alle fünf
Atomwaffenstaaten die offiziellen
Atomwaffen starten im Sicherheitsrat
gesagt hat ein Atomkrieg darf nie
geplant und auch nicht geführt werden
und wir wollten eine Bekräftigung dieser
Erklärung haben und haben gesagt die USA
und Russland sind die beiden
Atomwaffenstaaten die über 90 Prozent
aller Atomwaffen haben und sie müssen
mit konkreten Erklärung und schritten
gemeinsam vorangehen weil es ja immer
auch eine strategische Stabilität geben
soll und da haben wir eine Million
Unterschriften sehr schnell gesammelt
und sind dann auch bei der
abrüstungssekretärin der UNO eingeladen
worden und haben überlegt was können wir
denn die also gemeinsam überlegt was
können wir denn jetzt machen und die
inhumanitären Folgen des Atomkriegs sind
im Sicherheitsrat nicht bekannt und das
möchten wir vortragen
Frau brejunitzka es gibt jetzt vor allen
Dingen in Westeuropa diplomatische
mathematische Initiativen gefordert
Verhandlungslösungen sollen angestrebt
werden da gibt es sogar die Äußerung
dass der Westen einen Schritt auf den
Aggressor Putin zugehen soll um ihn aus
der Ecke rauszubringen indem er sich
selbst rein manövriert hat ist die Zeit
dafür eigentlich schon reif
ich denke die Zeit ist nicht nicht Ralf
die Gespräche zu führen im Westen dass
die Länder untereinander sprechen das
ist beraten wird das ist nach Strategien
gedacht wird und er Strategien
entwickelt werden dennoch ist es auch
sehr wichtig zu schauen welche
tatsächlichen Städte seitens Russland
unternommen werden und was wir sehen das
ist eine Verschärfung der Lage das ist
eine neue Stufe die erreicht wird ab 10
oktober wird die Ukraine flächendeckend
wieder bombardiert ab 10 Oktober war das
ein Tag an dem nach dem 24 februar am
stärksten am stärksten im ganzen Land
bombardiert wurde und genau darauf
sollte auch geschaut werden
diese Prozesse sollten parallel laufen
dennoch glaube ich dass die Gespräche
mit Putin direkt ein falsches Signal
setzen würden
welche Vorleistungen welche Bedingungen
müsste denn
Putin müsste Russland erfüllen damit es
tatsächlich zu solchen Gesprächen kommen
kann auch natürlich unter Beteiligung
und Zustimmung der Ukraine
dann müssten wir die ukrainischen
Partner befragen die Linsky hat ja
gesagt also es gibt keine Zugeständnisse
wenn Russland nicht die besetzten
Territorien räumt die Entscheidung
findet auf dem Schlachtfeld statt ja das
ist im Augenblick so und das ist auch
nachvollziehbar weil nicht die Ukraine
haben ja diesen Krieg begonnen sondern
die Russen und haben Tatsachen
geschaffen die im Augenblick so aussehen
dass immer noch erhebliche Teile der
Ukraine Territorien der Ukraine und so
wird der schaukurbation und Verwaltung
stehen ja aber man kann schwerlich von
den Ukrainern verlangen dass sie sagen
ach Schwamm drüber Hauptsache
Waffenstillstand ja und dann sehen wir
mal weiter das ist nicht zu erwarten sie
haben gefragt was man von den Russen
erwarten kann
da muss ich leider sagen nichts
weil dieser Krieg ist für die
dort regierende runter auch ein Krieg
zum eigenen Überleben und zum Überlegen
des governance-modells was der herrscht
nämlich im Wesentlichen ein Land zu
führen indem man gar irgendwie Mangas
und Öl in der Erde findet und das
verkauft international und dann diese
Renten umverteilt das ist die
Existenzgrundlage dieser Gruppierung und
sie wird nicht freiwillig da bin ich
sehr sicher
und davon lassen von daher habe ich da
leider keine positive Nachrichten auf
ihre Frage
man rätselt ja immer noch was Putin
eigentlich bewogen hat diesen
Angriffskrieg zu starten der hatte ja
schon den längeren Vorlauf auch weil er
sich nicht darüber im Klaren was
passieren kann was hat es passiert das
Land ist wirtschaftlich steht das am
Abgrund man hat ganz Europa und die
gesamte Nachbarschaft gegen sich
aufgebracht man kann sich kaum
vorstellen mit Russland in absehbarer
Zeit in friedlicher Nachbarschaft zu
leben eigentlich ist das was jetzt im
Moment in dem Krieg passiert ist und
welche Resultate Russland damit
sozusagen erreicht hat wahrscheinlich
genau das Gegenteil von dem was man sich
in Moskau Ende Februar gedacht hat wie
kommt es zu einer solchen
Fehleinschätzung oder ist das gar keine
Fehleinschätzung gewesen also ich glaube
es war eine fehlereinschätzung zunächst
mal müssen wir feststellen dass Russland
immer zwei Serien sozusagen von
Kriegszielen verfolgt hat lange Zeit
galt als klassisches Ziel die
Sicherheitspolitik im engeren Sinne das
heißt die NATO weit entfernt Verhalten
von den russischen Grenzen weil man
glaubte man könnte damit wenn man näher
rückt ein Art kuba-moment erzeugen
sondern dann die raketenflugzeiten oder
Kampfflugzeug Flugzeiten würden dann
geringer werden das war also der
klassische Stoff der Rüstungskontrolle
wie wir ihn mit Russland in 25 Jahren
den letzten 25 Jahre verhandelt haben es
hat sich darüber aber ein anderer Ductus
gelegt ein neoimperialer ein
revisionistischer Duktus der im Grunde
genommen auf die Wiedererrichtung des
zahnreiches oder der russischen Welt wie
man dort sagt abzielt und das ist geht
natürlich einher mit
völkerrechtsverletzung mit Verletzungen
auch der europäischen sicherheitsordnung
so wie wir sie auch mit Russland in der
oszd vereinbart haben und das ist
einfach nicht hinnehmbar das ist die
eine Seite
warum hat Russland trotzdem begonnen
oder Putin sagen sie begonnen weil man
die Ukraine und die ukrainische
Widerstandskraft völlig unterschätzt hat
man hat geglaubt die Ereignisse von 2014
wo tatsächlich der widerstandswelle
nicht sehr groß entwickelt war würden
sich einfach wiederholen da haben wir so
seinen Teil der ukrainischen Flotte
übergelaufen viele da Kräfte der Armee
wollten nicht kämpfen und der Widerstand
Rute im Wesentlichen auf den
freiwilligenbataillon das hat sich alles
völlig geändert die nationale Identität
die Putin ja bestreitet ist gewachsen
daran hat Putin einen großen Anteil und
er hat jetzt etwas erlebt was er wohl
nicht erwartet hat nämlich eine sehr
starke ukrainische Armee ein sehr
starken Willen auch die Einheit mit der
Bevölkerung und das hat zur ersten
großen Niederlage vor Kiew geführt das
ist glaube ich der Hauptgrund für diese
Fehleinschätzung
hinzufügen ja also einmal die restiliens
die Widerstandsfähigkeit der Ukraine
dramatisch unterschätzt ja zum anderen
aber auch die Einheit des Westens was
ihnen beeindruckt hat war die
katastrophale
abzugserfahrung der Westmächte aus
Afghanistan
hat uns alle sehr beeindruckt ja und er
hat sich vorgestellt und andere auch
dass die westliche Reaktion vielleicht
ähnlich sein würde wie sie hier auch
2014 nicht besonders tiefgehend und
dauerhaft war ja und das war nicht der
Fall und das war beides eine
völkerkulation für Klausen wenn man das
jetzt alles hören diese Umstände dieses
Krieges mit massiven Kriegsverbrechen in
butschern in anderen Städten zum
Beispiel noch dazu der Zerstörung der
systematischen Zerstörung von zivilen
Einrichtungen muss sie haben jetzt
gesagt USA und Russland müssen gemeinsam
bei Initiative ergreifen ist es nicht
doch so dass ich als allererstes
Russland da bewegen muss der
Bundespräsident hat auf der
Pressekonferenz wir haben diesen Satz
gerade nicht gezeigt unter anderem auch
noch gesagt es muss wenn der Frieden
dauerhaft sein soll muss es ein
gerechter Frieden sein ohne
Gerechtigkeit ohne einen gerechten
Frieden wird in wird es keinen Frieden
geben der dieser sogenannte Frieden
trägt schon den Keim des nächsten Sieges
in sich muss ich nicht als erstes
Russland bewegen
das können wir gerne fordern dass ich
Russland bewegen soll das finde ich auch
richtig dass ich Russland bewegen muss
wenn wir fordern dass sich Russland
bewegen soll dann müssen wir uns ja
realistisch überlegen
wird das eine einregime Putin oder die
Gruppe um Putin herum tun und was wir
bis jetzt erlebt haben in dem Krieg und
davon wissen ja die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine am meisten zu bringen ist das
erst nicht tot dass er quasi wie blind
oder wie nicht sag ich jetzt als ein
bisschen auch als Psychiaterin und
Psychotherapeutin die die Realitäten
nicht annimmt weil er so fixiert ist auf
also seine Machtstellung eben damit auch
so verbindet und wenn wir darüber reden
dass wir trotzdem
Friedensinitiative machen sondern
überlegen wir wo gibt es übergeord heute
übergeordnete Ziele die
vernünftig sein können und ein
vernünftiges Ziel ist
was ja auch schon wofür wir auch schon
uns eingesetzt haben ist eine
demilitarisierte Zone um das AKW
saporisa also dieses Atomkraftwerk so zu
lassen auch wenn es jetzt wird auch wenn
aller Reaktoren jetzt nicht am Netz sind
je länger dieser Krieg andauert
desto eher ist die Gefahr dass da
entweder ein die Kühlung unterbrochen
wird die Kühlkreisläufe und das betrifft
dann eben doch die Reaktoren oder die
abgebrannten Brennelemente dort und Jo
möchte das möchte ich noch als
hinzufügen die eio ist da schon alle
Atombehörde
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde ist ja
da schon aktiv geworden die Forderung
ist richtig und es ginge zum das wäre ja
ein Teilziel darum wie kann das jetzt
genau mit der Hilfe von welchen Staaten
um und durchgesetzt werden
ich werde Ihnen zu und denke mir so wäre
vielleicht all die Energie weil sie
machen ja wichtige Arbeit wäre
vielleicht sinnvoll all diese Energie
gegenüber dem russischen Staat so zu
richten und die die drum zu beten die zu
an die zu appellieren die aufzufordern
bitte aufzuhören in der Ukraine den
Krieg zu führen weil genau das Problem
haben wir und auch die die
militärisierte Zone um den AKW saporicia
wäre ja nichts anderes wenn der Abzug
russischer Kräfte stattfinden würde wenn
russische Soldaten da raus marschieren
würden dann hätten wir das Problem nicht
und ich frage mich weil es ich habe
immer noch so das Gefühl ein bisschen
dass der immer zu zweit zu beiden Seiten
gesprochen wird und da ist es wirklich
tatsächlich nicht der Fall dass die
Ukraine
gerne den Krieg führt ich übertreibe
jetzt es warum sitzt das Land sich
verteidigt und auch keine andere Wahl
hat keine andere Möglichkeit hat weil
sobald die Ukraine aufhört sich zu
verteidigen gibt es keine Ukraine und
ich wollte noch ganz kurz kommentieren
was Herr Richter gesagt hat zu dem Jahr
2014 ich denke dass der Wille der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung und das war
diese Resilienz und es war schon dieser
verteidigungsgeist schon schon damals
spürbar nur 2014 gab es keine
tatsächliche starke ukrainische Armee
und was wir 2014 erlebt haben nämlich
auch die Situation von der Westen nicht
so geschlossen hinter der Ukraine stand
das Professor Siegbert gerade
angesprochen hat das hat sich maßgeblich
zu dem Jahr 2022 Unterschieden aber
Menschen die Menschen waren schon bereit
es waren sehr viele Freiwillige die sich
beide Armee angemeldet haben und in den
in die östlichen Gebiete in die
kokupierten Gebiete in den Krieg gezogen
sind nicht nur dass das war einfach eine
andere Situation wo wirklich keine
Ausrüstung gab wo du Menschen wirklich
mit Turnschuhen in den Krieg gegangen
sind und die anderen haben die wollen
Tiere haben gesammelt und so weiter und
das ist nämlich auch ganz wichtig und an
der Stelle möchte ich das auch noch mal
betonen dass das ist auch ein
entscheidender Punkt dass der russische
Krieg in der Ukraine seit 2014 herrscht
das Russland diesen Krieg führt und
genau diese acht Monate waren auch eine
Zeit wo diese Resilienz der Bevölkerung
sich auch stärken konnte weil diese
Erfahrung schon gab also meine
Wahrnehmung von 2014 ist etwas anders
wir haben ja ich war auch selbst
involviert die Streitkräfte im Osten
also auch Russlands und der Ukraine
inspiziert wir wissen wie stark sie
waren die Ukraine hatte auch damals
schon die zweitstärkste Armee in Europa
mit Ausnahme der Türkei wenn ich die
jetzt mal weg lasse das heißt sie war
materiell ungeheuer stark ausgerüstet
sie hatten sie man konnte exportieren es
ist ja
rüstungsproduktionseinrüstungsproduktionsstaat
gewesen zumindest vor dem Krieg und der
Punkt der eigentliche Punkt den ich
machen will es gab aus der sehr großen
Armee von auch damals schon 180.000 Mann
etwa 6.7000 die sich wirklich an den
Kämpfen beteiligt haben und teilweise
hat man Kolonnen gesehen die sind
umgekehrt im Donbass weil dort
ältere Damen demonstriert haben und ein
Teil der ukrainischen Flotte ist
übergelaufen es gab einfach ein anderes
Gefühl auch gegenüber den Russen das
kommt aus alten sowjetischen Zeiten man
war Zahlweise auch familiär verwandelt
ich habe ja selbst bei den Inspektionen
gesehen wie nah man da war das hat sich
aber eben grundsätzlich geändert und das
ist das was Putin in acht Jahren zu Wege
gebracht hat er hat die nationale
Identität die er ja bestreitet der
Ukraine eigentlich durch seine Aktion
gefördert und war dann hoch überrascht
dass im Jahr 2022 sich alles völlig
anders entwickelt hat als er vielleicht
gedacht hat und das trifft natürlich
auch für die westliche Reaktion zu aber
ich will damit trotzdem noch einmal eine
Bresche schlagen auch für den Versuch
damals Deutschland und Frankreichs im
Normandie Format Schlimmeres zu verhüten
oder sollte man nicht nur als schwache
Reaktion des Westens bezeichnen
wir wenn wir wir suchen ja verzweifelt
eigentlich nach einem Möglichkeit wie
dieser Krieg zu Ende gehen könnte in
welchem Szenario er sieht das wenn
Russland seine militärischen Ziele nicht
erreicht auf was können sich Russland
auf was kann sich Putin dann einlassen
es gibt da verschiedene Forderungen
Rückzug auf die Grenzen vom 24 Februar
also nicht die Herausgabe von Grill und
irgendwas aber das was uns bei dem 24
Februar erobert hat Kriegsentschädigung
und Kriegsverbrecher vor Gericht stellen
was ist da realistisch und ist das hier
auch ist das auch ein Ansatzpunkt mit
Russland ins Gespräch zu kommen
ich denke das eine ganz wichtige
Voraussetzung für die Beantwortung Ihrer
Frage ist dass wir eine realistische
Vorstellung und selber verschaffen
mal locker etwas locker gesagt wie diese
Führungsgruppe in maskottiert
es ist nicht ein primäres Ziel dieser
Führungsgruppe irgendwelche Abkommen zu
schließen
wenn Sie irgendwelche Abkommen schließen
Russland ist das Land was in der letzten
20 Jahren wahrscheinlich die meisten
internationalen Abkommen gebrochen hat
ohne Ende und ohne Rücksicht
wie kommt es dass wir heute wieder
unsere Hoffnung darauf setzen sie sollen
irgendwann Abkommen schließen mit
irgendjemand sie werden es wenn Ihnen
das sinnvoll erscheint wieder brechen
und das ist nicht deshalb weil sie keine
rationalen Akteure sind das ist ja auch
eine Diskussion die wir haben in letzter
Zeit öfter sind es aber ticken überhaupt
rational ja das tun sie schon aber ihre
Präferenzen sind andere als unsere die
Präferenz von der Gruppe um den
Präsidenten lautet überleben und alles
was wissen überleben nützt wird auch
getan mit oder ohne Abkommen
von daher würde ich nicht darauf
so sehr den Akzent legen im Augenblick
sondern
auf die Frage was westliche Regierung
weiter dazu beitragen können
um den kleinen hoffnungsschema den wir
da vielleicht haben wir haben in der
letzten Wochen wir nie nach dem 24
Februar erlebt das ist auch andere
Alternative Stimmen gibt in der
Administration ja nicht ganz oben aber
zum Teil kurz darunter ja
um dieser Gruppe ganz klar zu machen
dass dieser Krieg von Russland nicht
gewonnen werden kann
und ob diese Klarheit und wann diese
Klarheit sich ein sich einstellt das hat
sehr viel damit zu tun wie wir künftig
weiter
umgehen mit der Ukraine ob wir jetzt
sehr stark in den Vordergrund den
Marshallplan schieben das ist sicher
meine gute Idee aber nicht für jetzt
unmittelbar oder ob wir überlegen was
fehlt im Augenblick am meisten das sind
ganz offensichtlich
luftabwehranlagen ja und ich denke dass
wir klar sehen müssen es ist nicht so
sehr das Ziel dass die Russen irgendwas
unterschreiben das ist nicht sehr viel
wert sondern dass ich in Russland auch
in den Apparaten
die Wahrheit allmählich Platz nimmt
Platz greift das Russland diesen Krieg
nicht gewinnen wird diese Notwendigkeit
militärische Verteidigung der Ukraine
das ja auch eine Position die
bundesaußenministerin vertritt die auch
gesagt hat im Moment sein
Verhandlungen völlig unsinnig sie sein
naiv diese Naivität die sei schon im
Jahre 2014 gescheitert die meinte wohl
das Minsker Abkommen selbst wenn richte
da jetzt auch für das normandie-format
eine Lanze gebrochen hat ja
im Moment ist es tatsächlich schwer sich
vorzustellen dass man das was sie ja
erwarten dass Verhandlungen dazu führen
dass die Waffen schweigen dass das
irgendeine realistische Chance aufs auf
Erfolg hat ich finde dass wir zu
einseitig diskutieren ich glaube wir
müssen zwei Sachen machen wir müssen
Putin darf den Krieg nicht gewinnen
damit bin ich einverstanden aber wir
müssen den Frieden auch auf Dauer mit
Russland und mit
müssen wir auch gewinnen das wird kein
Prozess sein der irgendwie jetzt mal so
eben
vonstatten gehen wird aber wir müssen
trotzdem uns doch darauf vorbereiten
dass dass wir auch mit einem Russland in
Europa leben werden und wir haben diesen
Punkt möchte ich auch noch ansprechen
wir haben die drängende Klimakrise mit
wem wollen wir denn in Russland
es wird nicht mit Putin sein da bin ich
auch überzeugt aber wir müssen doch in
mit einer Regierung in Russland auch
über die Klimakrise sprechen wir müssen
doch über den Permafrost und das
Auftauen des permafrostbusen sprechen
können es muss doch internationale
gemeinsame kooperative
Aktionen geben damit das die Klimakrise
zumindest eingedämmt wird und wir haben
zwei Bedrohungen im 21 Jahrhundert das
ist die Klimakrise und das ist die
Gefahr eines Atomkriegs und beide sind
Menschen gemacht beide müssen zusammen
angegangen werden und wir müssen einen
Weg finden ich sage jetzt immer muss
muss muss muss ich weil ich mir darüber
im Klaren bin dass es schwierig und
komplex ist und das ist nur in
Schritten gehen wird und nicht sofort
aber wir können noch nicht nur die
andere Seite also wir können auch den
Frieden nicht vergessen und ich bin hier
um für den Frieden und wie wir auch den
Frieden tun können zu sprechen
wie sehen die Menschen in der Ukraine
das diese diese friedensdimension ist
das Spiel das im Moment also Frieden mit
Russland zum Beispiel gute Nachbarschaft
irgendeine Rolle im in den Gedanken der
Ukraine Menschen in der Ukraine sowie
Menschen in Deutschland und auf aller
Welt wollen auch Frieden ich denke hier
sind wir uns einig und auch Menschen in
der Ukraine und in Deutschland und in
anderen Ländern wünschen sich auch keine
Kriege nur ich möchte hier
unterstreichen dass Russland gerade den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine mitten in Europa
führt und das ist Fakt und ich glaube
darüber streiten wir uns nicht und ich
finde es ist wichtig absolut wichtig
andere Themen mit einzubeziehen in
diesen Diskurs aber wir reden primär
darum wie man mit Russland umgehen muss
in der Situation und ich sehe das als
eine sehr große Chance in jetzigen
Zeitpunkt auch die russ Politik zu
überdenken und ich hatte im Studium
gelernt man sollte Situationen anhand
vielleicht von Indikatoren auswerten und
was macht sie dazu was bewegt sie dazu
jetzt auch darüber zu denken das
Russland mit Russland könnte man
vorhanden mit Russland könnte man
Abkommen schließen mit Russland könnte
man etwas machen was darauf hoffen lässt
es ist verlässlich ist was lässt sie
daran glauben in den letzten acht Jahren
was wir erlebt haben einfach diese
Analyse in Hinblick auch auf Deutschland
sicherheitspolitische energiepolitisch
Zivilgesellschaft was lässt sie glauben
dass man mit der jetzigen Regierung
sowie in der Konstellation die sie haben
sich verhandeln lässt die Frage wäre
auch nach der zeitlichen Dimension die
Frage wäre ich möchte als sich der
Ukraine wie gesagt ich möchte einfach
eine Meinung dazu äußern und das ist
auch eine Frage die ich an sie richte
was lässt sie glauben dass wenn wir
jetzt vorhanden weil ich habe das Gefühl
dass über Verhandlungen sprechen Dialog
ist wichtig ohne Frage man sollte die
Strategien sich überlegen die man sich
in der Situation verhält und was lässt
sie glauben dass diese wenn man jetzt
irgendwelche
Verhandlungen angeht das ist daran
gehalten wird versehen das mit jedem
Schritt seit acht Monaten ich war ich
warte jetzt nicht die letzten 8 Jahre
und selbst da wäre die Analyse sehr
wertvoll die aus meiner Sicht nicht
geführt wird aber nehmen wir die achten
die acht letzten Monate es gibt ständige
Verschärfung der sension der der
Situation seitens Russland Russland
zerstört seit 10 Oktober verschärft und
seit letzten Monaten und seit letzten
Jahren auch die Ukraine und seit dem 10
sind ab also bis heutigen Zeitpunkt sind
über 30% der kritischen und sie werden
Infrastruktur zerstört warum reden wir
nicht darüber
wir reden ja darüber und Sie haben ja
völlig Recht die Ukraine ist im Moment
das
Opfer einer Aggression und Russland hat
natürlich die Fenster der Gelegenheit
sozusagen geschlossen mit der Annexion
das ist für die Ukraine nicht
verhandelbar für den Westen auch nicht
es gab aber eine Zeit davor ich nehme
dann mal den 29 März als es noch
Verhandlungen tatsächlich gab in
Istanbul die dann Präsident selensky
auch persönlich aufgenommen hat und wo
es dann aus der russischen Delegation
zumindest positive Geräusche gab und das
muss man glaube ich noch mal deutlich
machen was da gesagt worden ist erstens
die krimlösung wird um 15 Jahre
verschoben und dann noch mal aufgemacht
das heißt das ist ja eine defacto
Anerkennung der russischen Kontrolle
nicht der jure also nicht rechtlich aber
de facto für eine gewisse Zeit um das zu
beruhigen zweitens es wird zwischen den
beiden Präsidenten ein Sonderstatus wird
in Donbass ausgehandelt das hat mich so
an Minsk erinnert und könnte ein Minsk 3
werden und drittens die Ukraine bietet
auf den NATO-Beitritt eine alte
Forderung Russlands und es gab ja selbst
in der Nacht und dazu keine Einheit und
dazu noch Sicherheitsgarantien und
einige andere Dinge die sowieso klar
sind humanitäre Dinge Gefangenen
Austausch usw das waren eigentlich
vernünftige Vorschläge und ich frage
mich bis heute warum dort an dieser
Stelle nicht weitergemacht worden war
sie haben völlig recht jetzt mit diesen
Annexion ist dieses verhandlungsfenster
so gut wie geschlossen und die Frage ist
auf welche Weise bringt man Russland zu
Erkenntnis dass diese Art der Politik
ins Abseits führt und das so der Krieg
auch nicht beendet werden kann das heißt
aber nicht dass wir aufhören darüber
nachzudenken wie man diesen Krieg
beendet wir müssen natürlich wird ein
Krieg immer durch zwei Möglichkeiten
beendet durch einen Siegfrieden das
heißt die totale Niederlage einer Seite
der totale Sieg der anderen wir wissen
in der unserer Geschichte wovon wir
reden oder eben durch Verhandlungen es
gibt kaum eine andere Möglichkeit es sei
denn wir wollen diesen sich in die Länge
ziehen und das führt ja auch zu endlosen
Zerstörungen etc das ist verbunden und
hier ist der Unterschied zur normalen
Situation für Kriege mit anderen Staaten
mit das ist verbunden mit der
grundsätzlichen Gefahr einer Eskalation
wir sprechen hier über neben den USA den
größte die größte nuklear macht dieser
Erde und je mehr und da haben sie ja
auch recht je mehr diese Führung die
politische Führung sich in eine Ecke
gedrängt zieht umso mehr könnten sich
auch die kalkülle verschieben die eine
solche Eskalation hervorrufen für uns
ist das alles völlig irrational
eigentlich jede Art der Eskalation aber
die kalkülle verschieben sich wenn sie
selbst dagegen setzen den Wert Ihres
eigenen wenn auch nur politischen
Überlebens oder nicht das heißt wir sind
in der Ecke
im Moment vielleicht durchaus weil er ja
ganz andere Wege geht er versucht ja zu
mobilisieren Personal zu generieren den
luftkriegt zu intensivieren vielleicht
sogar eine weitere Front aufzubauen aus
Belarus heraus das sind alles noch
Schwierigkeiten der Eskalation im
konventionellen Bereich das heißt aber
nicht dass wir nicht aufpassen müssen in
der wohl verstandenen Unterstützung der
Ukraine nicht auch an das andere Ende
der Spektrums zu denken und immer zu
überlegen was sind Schritte die zu
dieser Eskalation führen können und was
müssen wir Russland deutlich
signalisieren ich glaube Präsident
beiden tut das ja auch und letztlich auf
der Kanzler oder Präsident macron das
ist auch gewisse Grenzen gibt und dass
wir natürlich ist allesamt auch von
maximalzielen Abstand nehmen also eine
Ruinierung Russlands was ja oft auch im
Westen zum Teil also in extremer Form
gesagt worden ist eine Ruinierung auf
Dekaden der russischen Armee oder der
Wirtschaft das sollten wir tun ist
lassen sondern ein vernünftigen
Mittelweg gehen der immer auch sieht
dass die eskalationsgefahren bestehen
ich würde gerne kurz
ganz kurz die Zwischenfrage stellen aber
es wäre der der Mittelweg den sich hier
ansprechen weil so wie ich mich richtig
entsinnen nach den letzten Verhandlungen
war das Problem dass zum einen die
Getreide nicht ausgeführt werden konnte
und zum anderen was die Welt
Fu Security gefährdet und zum anderen
wurde die Ukraine weiterhin maßgeblich
bombardiert das wäre ein Indikator
wiederum dafür dass diese Eskalation
steigt und was wäre der Mittelweg ich
würde gerne das Wissen ihre einschätzen
ja überhaupt nicht
das ist ein getreideabkommen gibt zeigt
dass es zu gewissen Dingen eben doch
Verhandlungen gibt die auch zum Erfolg
führen können dasselbe gilt für den
Gefangenenaustausch leider ist diese
Friedenslösung im Moment überhaupt nicht
in sich da stimme ich in völlig zu weil
Putin mit in Annexion dieses Fenster
einfach geschlossen hat und wir weit
entfernt sind vom 29 März aber ich will
immer ein Beispiel geben wenn Präsident
beiden sagt ich unterstütze die Ukraine
mit Heimatsystem dann gibt es ja zwei
Möglichkeiten nämlich die
Langstreckenrakete zu liefern die über
180 km etwa fliegt oder nur eine kürzere
die Langstreckenrakete will er nicht
liefern weil er vermeiden will dass die
Ukraine über die Grenzen nach Russland
schießt das bedeutet also dass die
Möglichkeiten oder diese Erwägung eines
eskalatorischen Charakters der den der
Krieg nehmen kann ja nicht eine rein
deutsche Überlegung ist sondern durchaus
auch eine amerikanische ich würde gerne
wir stimmen die Frage die sie gerade
noch aufgeworfen haben wie ist der Krieg
zu beenden er sich besser haben
Abgeordnete der FDP und der
bündnisgründen im Bundestag ganz klare
Vorstellung sie sagen nur
Waffenlieferungen und zwar noch
verstärkte Waffenlieferung vor allem
schwere Waffenlieferungen werden Putin
zum Einlenken zwingen und nicht nur
diese Forderung erheben sie sondern sie
sagen auch Deutschland sollte bei der
militärischen Unterstützung also dieser
Waffenlieferungen wenn ich das jetzt
richtig verstanden habe auch so eine Art
Führungsrolle übernehmen möglicherweise
auch weil der Vorwurf gegen Deutschland
immer wieder kam man würde zu wenig tun
für die Verteidigungsfähigkeit der
Ukraine ist das ein Weg der sich da
auftut
also eine Führungsrolle von Deutschland
überzeugt mich hier nicht unbedingt vor
allen Dingen ein Gesichts diese obskuren
beschaffungsadministration der wir in
den letzten 50 Jahren aufgebaut haben
und die auch dazu geführt haben dass die
Bundeswehr selbst nicht in sehr guten
ausrüstungszustand sich befindet ich
möchte auf einen Punkt noch mal
hinweisen
die
Entscheidung des russischen Präsidenten
der letzten drei bis vier Wochen zum
Beispiel die sogenannte teilweise
Mobilisierung
hat endlich dazu beigetragen dass der
Krieg der für die meisten Russen bis
dahin weit weg war und ich spürbar war
nun wirklich in den meisten Familien
angekommen ist weil es betrifft fast
seine Familie und das ist ein großes
Problem für
die Annexion diese vier administrativen
Einheiten hier noch nicht mal
kontrolliert und im Augenblick weniger
als zu dem Zeitpunkt wo das aufgerufen
wurde ist ebenfalls ein Problem es war
seine Idee wenn er sich darauf einlassen
würde das wieder zu Disposition zu
stellen
und daraus zu gehen oder das auf den
Tisch an Verhandlungstisch zu legen dann
hätte er ein großes Problem und das
Problem wäre nicht wie wir am besten oft
vermuten irgendwelche Reste von
liberaler Öffentlichkeit die der
vielleicht demonstriert sondern das
Problem wäre ganz im Gegenteil die
nationalpatriotische Seite in Russland
die eine unglaublichen unerwertete
Renaissance genommen hat in der letzten
Wochen und Monaten und massiven Druck
ausübt auf dem Präsidenten die sogar
Parallelstrukturen in Form einer
paramilitärischen Organisation oder gar
eine Armee aufbauen will ja und
Ultimaten stellt und sehr viele
Förderungen stellt und zum Teil glaubt
er den Nachkommen zu müssen wenn er
jetzt nachdem er teilweise diese
Schritte auf diese Gruppe zugeteilt hat
weil im liberalen Spektrum ist nichts
auf dass er sich stützen kann das sind
emigriert oder im Gefängnis oder wer
weiß was ja
dann würde er definitiv seine eigene
Position zu Disposition stellen das habe
ich eben schon gesagt das kann er nicht
tun das wird er nicht tun das heißt je
enger die Option für entwerden durch die
Entwicklung auf dem Schlachtfeld je
enger sie werden
desto größer seine Problematik was er
tun soll und desto eher die Chance für
die Ukraine und auch für die anderen
europäischen Länder das ist vielleicht
zu einer Situation kommt wo
das Monopol dieser engen Gruppe und
Putin auf die Macht stärker noch bedroht
wird als es im Augenblick der Fall ist
ich denke das ist das Einzige das was
weiterhilft solange sie haben das eben
angedeutet im Umsatz zu lange dieser
derzeitige Präsident in diesem Amt liegt
verbleibt werden wir nicht weiterfahren
wenn möglicherweise wird man ja
vielleicht den Teufel mit den Welt zu
buchen austreiben wenn man das jetzt
sich so ansieht was ist das für
Möglichkeiten gibt und kaum Hoffnung auf
einen echten Frieden ist wenn ich die
Gefahr groß dass das optimale passieren
kann ein sogenannter eingefrorener
Konflikt ist frozen Konflikt da haben
wir viele auf der Erde zwischen
serbienem Kosovo zwischen Serbien und
Bosnien am 38 Breitengrad in Korea
zwischen Indien Pakistan und Kaschmir
das war ein neuer
Zypern
geteilt zwischen
Griechen und Türken dass da ein neuer
frozen-konflikt
entsteht das hat eingefrorener Konflikt
der uns Jahrzehnte jetzt erstmal wieder
in Atem hält
das kann natürlich sein trotzdem
befürchte ich dass es nicht zutreffen
wird weil ich diese
Eskalationsspirale viel viel größer und
viel stärker sehe und ich denke dass wir
schon auf die ganze Welt ist betroffen
das haben wir jetzt alle auch mehrfach
gesagt und warum kann dann nicht zum
Beispiel china hat ja seine Macht jetzt
stabilisiert ich denke dass auch innere
starten und gerade auch China
Herrn Putin sagen müsste
also die nukleare Eskalation die weitere
Eskalation geht so nicht und das kann er
meinetwegen im Telefonat alleine machen
dass sie nicht jede Eskalation
akzeptieren richtig also es gab ja vor
kurzem ich weiß nicht genau wie dieses
Format heißt wo sich Russland auch China
und schöne
organisationenorganisation auch Indien
getroffen haben und dort haben sowohl
China als auch Indien als auch
Kasachstan ein gewissen Abstand ein
gewissen Abstand genommen ohne jetzt
Putin schärfsten zu kritisieren oder so
oder so also in diese Richtung könnten
doch auch
Präsident beiden unsere
eu-führerinnen und führ wir könnten doch
zu den Staaten Kontakt aufnehmen und
sagen wir möchten also wir fragen euch
könnt ihr nicht mehr zur Beruhigung
beitragen das ist ein riesengroßer Welt
internationaler Konflikt ich würde gerne
ich würde ganz gerne noch ein Aspekt wir
haben nicht mehr so lange Zeit Frau
Metzger noch mal ansprechen es ist ja in
Berlin diese Wirtschaftskonferenz jetzt
gewesen gestern und heute da ging es um
wirtschaftliche Aufbauhilfe für die
Ukraine nach der Beendigung des Krieges
erst natürlich was versprechen sich die
Ukraine davon denn das funktioniert ja
nur das was da geplant ist was jetzt
schon sinnvollerweise vorbereitet wird
funktioniert ja nur wenn tatsächlich
Frieden dort herrscht irgendwie welche
Hoffnungen haben die Ukraine in Bezug
auf diesen Wiederaufbau die
väteraufbaukonferenz die heute den Tag
stattfand da werden Gespräche geführt
die nicht nur den wieder aufbauen nach
dem nach der Beendigung des Krieges
diskutieren sondern es geht darum wie
man jetzt in die jetzigen Situation
schon vorgehen kann welche Maßnahmen
getroffen werden und das ist notwendig
natürlich dass es notwendig darüber zu
sprechen auch über den sogenannten
Marshallplan für die Ukraine gemeinsam
zu diskutieren die Maßnahmen sich zu
überlegen und auch aktiv zu werden aber
worüber wir jetzt sprechen und zunehmend
sprechen sollten welchen Plan für den
Winter wir haben und ich hatte mir jetzt
so einige Gedanken gemacht dass wir
jetzt eigentlich brauchen aber was was
jetzt notwendig wird für den Winter und
natürlich ihr auch in Hinblick auf
Wiederaufbau auf die Aufbau der oder
Reparatur oder zerstörten Infrastruktur
auf die Reparatur der zerstörten
wohnhäuse zivile Bezirke
was dringend notwendig ist denn eine
eine humanitäre Katastrophe im Winter
uns offensichtlich erwartet wäre es
wichtig auch natürlich auch jetzt
darüber zu sprechen möglicherweise auch
meine letzte Frage in der Sendung schon
erahnt genau darum wollte ich nämlich
noch mal ansprechen Herr Richter
russland versucht ja die vor dem Winter
jetzt die Energieversorgung und die
Struktur der Ukraine regelrecht Platz zu
machen zu zerbomben welchen Einfluss hat
denn jetzt dieser Angriff gerade auf die
Energieversorgung vor dem Winter auf den
Verlauf des Krieges oder welchen
Einfluss könnte das auf den Verlauf des
Krieges haben
ich glaube es wird keinen allzu großen
Einfluss haben denn wenn auch die
Energieversorgung zum großen Teil
beschädigt ist also zu 40 Prozent
beschädigt ist glaube ich nicht dass die
Widerstandskraft der Menschen deswegen
nachlässt was sicherlich ein Punkt ist
ist dass die Eisenbahn die zum großen
Teil elektrifiziert läuft eingeschränkt
ist das ist wichtig weil die Logistik
von West nach Ost zum Beispiel über die
Eisenbahn in erster Linie läuft die wird
behindert das hat dann Einfluss auf der
anderen Seite bewegen wir uns auf einen
abnutzungskrieg zu denn beide Seiten
also die Ukraine wird unterstützt vom
Westen die Russen werden versuchen
weitere Reserven zu mobilisieren bis die
dann alle an der Front sind das wird
noch viel dauern und in der Zwischenzeit
werden sie ihren Luftkrieg intensivieren
ich befürchte also wir sehen kein Ende
im Winter sondern wir sehen mehr
Zerstörung wir sehen eine Fortsetzung
des Krieges und Kollegen nutzt der
abnutzungskrieg mehr der Ukraine oder
Russland
ich bin nicht so ganz sicher ob es
wirklich ein abnutzungskrieg ist obwohl
ich die Argumente verstehe das russische
Kalkül ist nicht so sehr nur die Ukraine
zu treffen und ins Chaos zu stürzen
sondern daraus abgeleitet erneut riesige
Flüchtlingsströme zu generieren die dann
in Westeuropa aufschlagen und dann die
europäischen EU internen Probleme
verschärfen wir haben da nämlich keinen
Konsens im Augenblick und auch die
Energieprobleme nach füttern verschärfen
die werden Westeuropa haben das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren aber
es ist das Spiel was im Kreml angedacht
ist
gut dann müssen wir an dieser Stelle
einen Punkt machen aber nur
vorübergehend bis zum nächsten bis zur
nächsten Phönix Runde mit diesem Thema
ich bedanke mich bei den Natalia
brechaniska bei Angelika Klausen bei
Professor Klaus Siegbert und bei
Wolfgang Richter Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix
Runde Personalmangel und Pleitewelle
Krankenhäuser am Limit
weiteres und aktuelles bei Königs der
Tag mit Maja Weber Thema darin noch mal
ausführlich Berichte über den Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten in Kiew bleiben Sie
bei uns
[Musik]